all right well texas is now arresting
migrants illegally crossing the border
on trespassing charges
more than 30 now confined to an empty
state prison up from 10
just last week this as the
administration has quietly resumed a
trump era policy
accelerating the removal of migrants and
families to
curb they say the surging spread of
covid
it's a desperate attempt is it working
texas gop congressman tony gonzalez
congressman how much worse has this
gotten and how much better
has operation lone star been for people
in your community
yeah things are as bad as they've ever
been it hasn't gotten better it's only
gotten worse
and and sadly texans feel as if we're
alone
and we we see it you know we're doing
everything we possibly can
to fight against this immigration crisis
but the big guy
is awol kamala harris is a wall i mean
federal government is nowhere to be
found
texans are having to take care of texans
as we fight through this pandemic
a couple months ago my county judges
were asking for more body bags
i had to work with the texas division of
emergency management to get them more
body bags
and guess what now they're asking for
even more body bags
right because the summer months are here
and the journey is more dangerous you
famously were
at a ranch where we saw little girls who
were abandoned um you you put that story
out there
you're a dad of six children i can
relate to that
um especially as a congressman how
the left the democrats claim that their
open border policy
is compassionate talk to me about how
it's not compassionate for
texans and how it's hurting those who
are coming across as well
yeah their open border rhetoric that is
turned into open border policy is
dangerous
it's and it's killing people it's
killing migrants it's creating this
chaos
you're seeing a a spike in covid cases
uh i'm getting i'm getting told on the
ground in these detention facilities
that the numbers are reaching upper to
20 percent wow so it's not
it's absolutely out of control and
they're going about it the wrong way you
know you've got 1.1 million
illegal immigrants that have come
through and they're encouraging
even more this administration should
focus on legal immigration reform
instead they're creating this chaos and
sadly migrants are dying horrible deaths
imagine running out of water in the
middle of a desert imagine being stuck
in a u-haul
i mean it's absolutely uh despicable
what's happening
sure and at the same time the government
because the this administration has
given ice
new marching orders where if you want to
arrest somebody you got to call the
front office
they have apparently focused part of
their mission
and they are now cracking down on sex
offenders and since the month of june
which was just last month
they've already arrested and are in the
process of deporting
300 sex offenders congressman this at
the same time
joe biden's administration is spending
two billion dollars
to simply stop building the wall which
obviously
a lot of people would say we really need
oh yeah
experts on the ground tell me we need
three things we need a wall
we need technology and we need boots on
the ground these are the people that
live it every day
what is what is joe biden doing he's
defunding the wall
he's not adding any technology and and
the appropriations we're about to
vote on appropriations bills this week
the appropriations bill
defund border patrol and ice by one
billion dollars
does that sound like somebody who's
trying to tackle the problem it's the
exact opposite
yeah they have open waters they put out
expedited removal but it's going to be a
short time if you come up with any stop
story
you'll be allowed to stay kamal harris
nowhere to be found and of course
two billion dollars is being spent to
settle deals with contractors
uh on the fence on the wall to either
destroy it or store it
and that's on taxpayers expense we're
paying not to have a barrier
incredible congressman thanks so much
thank you
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox you can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now